موجها الى السماء وفي حاله تاهب هذا
السلاح المضاد للطائرات سوفيه الصنع انتج
عام 82
متنقله يحاولون حمايه العاصمه الاوكرانيه
والمناطق المحيطه بها من المسيرات الروسيه
المتفجره والهجمات الصاروخيه
بعض الاخيره
هذا السعودي
يقول القائد هنا انها فعاله ويصير مداها 6
كيلومترات لكن غالبا ما يجدون صعوبه في
اسقاط الطائرات بدون طياره التي تستخدمها
روسيا لاستهداف شبكه الكهرباء
القوات الروسيه نفذت ملا يقل عن الف هجوم
بطائرات مسيره وصواريخ كروز سادفت عبرها
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في الفتره الاخيره
معظم الهجمات المماثله لهذا يجري اعتراضها
من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي ونقص التدفئه
في ظل الشتاء فارس
الولايات المتحده الاسبوع الماضي
تبلغ اربعه ملايين دولار
بوكيمون
ستستخدم فقط لحمايه الاهداف المحتمله
الاهم ولا يمكن نشرها لاعتراض الطائرات
بدون الطيار وصواريخ كروز
الان صوت صفاره انذار بعيده انه انذار
دفاع جوي وهذا يعني ان هؤلاء الرجال يجب
ان يتحرك
ويمكره بسهوله
الجزيره